raphaël beau riche devient 35 ans le
plus jeune président du chili leader
étudiant des manifestations de 2011 il
rebondit sur la révolte populaire de
2019 dans les rues du chili pour offrir
un programme progressiste dans un pays
qui vit encore dans l'héritage
économique de la dictature d'augusto
pinochet
son adversaire rose et antonio caste lui
concède la victoire un peu plus d'une
heure après la fermeture des bureaux de
vote par twitter il dit qu'il a appelés
et féliciter son adversaire pour son
grand triomphe et que le président élu
mérite respect et collaboration
constructive
d'origine allemande l'ultra-conservateur
caste assume ouvertement son admiration
pour jaillir ball sonar aux aidants
altran
un populiste qui de façon surprenante
est arrivé en tête au premier tour de
l'élection
une forte participation le vote des
jeunes à creuser la différence en faveur
du candidat de gauche il veut réformer
le système de pensions de retraites
privatiser qui pèse lourd sur les
revenus de nombreux chiliens ainsi que
les systèmes de santé d'éducation
la révolte populaire de 2019 pour plus
de justice sociale a conduit à
l'élection d'une assemblée constituante
celle ci doit rédiger une nouvelle
constitution pour remplacer celle que le
chili a hérité de la dictature et qui
sera soumise à référendum probablement
septembre 2022
posez antonio castrais tout fait pour
torpiller le projet gabriel boric lui
assure un avenir il devra cependant
gouverner avec une forte opposition de
droite au congrès qui démontre que celle
ci est encore puissante au chili trente
ans après la fin de la dictature
jean-michel le prince serait du canada
montréal